ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So you're
new to Google Cloud Platform.
Maybe you would like to simply
check out GCP's breadth,
deploy some
application of yours,
or learn about Google Cloud's
big data and machine learning
capabilities.
In any case, welcome.
Let me show you around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So first things first,
cloud.google.com
is your starting point.
This is where you will
find all the product
information and documentation,
but also detailed solutions
with architectures and code
with many different use cases.
Pricing is also detailed there,
including Google's pricing
principles and a detailed
cost calculator for every GCP
product and service.
Cloud.google.com is also
the place to access support,
to read customer stories,
to find partners,
and to understand
how Google Cloud
Platform is different
from other public clouds.
The Google Cloud Console
is where you will likely
spend a fair amount of
time exploring and using
the platform.
This is where you configure
building accounts,
create and manage projects,
and manage all your GCP
resources, regardless of
their data center location.
Every product and every
service has its own section
in the console left-hand
menu, with dashboards,
detailed configurations,
and settings.
You will also find interactive
quick start experiences
from right inside the console.
Take this example quick
start for Compute Engine.
Simply walk through the
various steps of the tutorial,
and within minutes, you'll be
running a Node.js application
with its back end on Compute
Engine virtual machines.
The Cloud Console also
offers a marketplace
with ready-to-go software stacks
to accelerate development,
so you spend less
time installing
and more time developing.
This allows you to deploy
production-grade solutions
in a few clicks with
a single bill for all
your GCP and third-party
costs, and it also
offers direct access
to partner support.
To make sure you set
up your employees up
with the right permissions to
use different GCP resources,
Cloud Console also integrates
Identity and Access Management,
or Cloud IAM, and
provides a unified view
into security policy across
your entire organization.
This is also where you
would manage quotas
across the platform.
Every product comes with
one or more usage limits
across the platform, so
you can prevent one team
from spending the entire
[INAUDIBLE] budget
on a rote query or compute job.
If you'd like, you may even use
our iOS and Android mobile apps
to monitor and manage your
GCP applications on the go.
Finally, one can sign up
for affordable support
for both development and
production phases right
from the console.
This role-based support
enables configuration
on a per-user basis,
and case management
is integrated into
Cloud Console.
While the console is
powerful and flexible,
you can do everything
from the command line.
For every action in the console,
there is a gcloud equivalent.
gcloud is our scriptable
and almighty CLI,
and it comes with
the Google Cloud SDK.
Cloud Shell is a
shell environment
hosted on Google Cloud Platform
for managing your projects
and resources.
It is accessible from
a simple web browser
and is powered by a
small virtual machine
with persistent disk
and up-to-date software
for all your development needs.
It even comes with
a web code editor.
If you'd like to know more
about developer tools,
check out the video linked
in the description below.
Before you can use
GCP Cloud Console,
you will need a Google account.
You can create a
new Google account
or use an existing one,
such as your Gmail account.
We recommend that you enable
billing for your project,
and that you sign up
for our free trial.
If you do not
enable billing, you
will not be able
to use GCP products
beyond their free tier.
If you do not sign up
for the free trial,
or if you're not
eligible, you can still
benefit from that GCP
generous always free tier.
You will find more details about
the free tier and free trial
in an upcoming video.
Once logged into
the GCP Console,
I would recommend that you
check out the main menu,
and in particular, the
Getting Started section.
Start with a short tour
of the platform tutorial.
In a few minutes, you
will get a good sense
of how to get the best
out of Cloud Console.
Next, scroll to
Interactive Tutorials,
and take a short hands-on lab
for the topic of your choice
without leaving the console.
Finally, check out the
main categories product
GCP has to offer--
compute, storage,
networking, Stackdriver
for everything DevOps,
tools, big data,
and artificial intelligence.
As you progress through
your discovery of GCP,
keep in mind those
key resources--
documentation, in-depth
tutorials, support, training,
and free code labs.
GCP can be
overwhelming at first.
But with this small
guidance, we hope
that you are now confident
that your best ideas can
come to life in the cloud.
We're certainly excited
to see what you build
and look forward
to your feedback.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to
more GCP Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]